- It's time for Drew's Love Bug,
where we explore all things love
from dating to marriage,
and certified dating coach
and our friend of the show,
Damona Hoffman is here,
and she and I have a lot to say today.
Hi Damona.
(crowd applauds)
- Hey Drew.
- Looking beautiful on the
inside and out as always.
- Thank you (laughs).
- Okay.
- I'm ready to help people in love.
- I know, and you're, you
have been happily married
for a long time, and so, and you know,
I'm a divorcee, and I love
that we both come at it
from different points
of view, but I always
love your advice.
It is so salient.
It is just, I'm so happy to be a partner
in this with you,
because we're all contending
with relationships.
No matter what.
- Absolutely.
- And so.
And it can be really complicated
if we make it complicated.
But I like to make it easy.
And like you, I love love.
- I absolutely love your approach,
and it should be easy, and actually,
okay, we're gonna get
right into questions,
because I'm just, I could
talk about this all day long.
Okay, Shana is here,
and she has a question
about online dating.
- Hi, so I jumped back
on the dating app Hinge,
which I had success within the past.
Not really having success making
those quality connections.
How do I move forward with initiating
the initial call or virtual
date without being super weird?
- Damona.
(Damona laughs)
- Shana, it's only weird
if we make it weird.
You, it sounds like you're
stuck in what I call
the texting trap.
It's really easy to
think that you can filter
through all of these messages online,
but I want to help you break out of that.
And you can do that by
inviting an invitation.
And it doesn't have to be weird.
You can just say, "I would
love to tell you more
about that when we meet for a date."
And then your man is
invited to pick up the phone
or take you out on a date.
Because we can sure waste a lot of time.
So your love lesson Shana
is to not spend more
than one week after you match with someone
before you do a phone call or a date.
That's it, that will
save you a lot of time,
a lot of heartache.
- I love that.
That is super amazing to
get a goal and a timeline.
And Alex, if it's any consolation,
I tried a dating app,
and I got the same thing.
No follow through.
So Damona, I like your timeline.
Shana, I'm so sorry, Alex is the one
who is actually coming here.
We have a question from the fellas.
Alex is struggling to find the one.
Alex, what's your question?
- Hey Drew Barrymore.
So I feel like I'm Mr. Un-dateable.
I've been burned a lot in the past.
And after a while, it, you know,
it's hard to stay the nice guy.
So my question is, you
know, how can I trust
and get back into the dating process again
after like a recent heartbreak
or rejection you know?
Am I un-dateable?
- I don't think so Drew.
I think everyone is dateable,
and I think nice guys win.
I married one.
I did this whole dating plan
called Operation Date Nice Guys.
I'll tell you about it another time.
But here's the thing Alex.
What happens when we have heartbreak
and when we have relationships
that don't work out,
we bring that pain with us
to the next relationship.
And we put up these walls that prevent you
from really being yourself.
And I don't know if you heard Alex,
but I would say that
vulnerability is the new black.
It's very sexy.
So when you bring your
whole self into the room,
that's when you'll be
able to make your match.
So here's your love lesson Alex.
I would say try
- Okay.
- to take down those
walls without worrying
about the ultimate outcome,
because the ones who
are not right for you,
absolutely they will run for the hills.
But the one who is right, and
we're only looking for one,
she will see all those
wonderful qualities about you.
- I totally agree Damona.
And you know what, I
promise you this Alex,
nice guys do finish last.
So enjoy being single, because one day,
in an instant,
(fingers snap)
it will be gone, and
you will find the girl
who realizes that when
it's nice, and less drama,
and really functioning, and you
guys have to work at things,
but it feels really right,
that is where we all end up.
And that is the right
place to be I believe.
(upbeat music)